[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم قتل اذا
34 شخصا واصيب اكثر من 50 في تفجيرات
متزامنه ضربت مطار بروكسل و محطه قطارات
انفاق في المدينه صباح الثلاثاء وبعيد ذلك
بساعات اعلنت وكاله اعماق التابعه لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه مسؤوليه التنظيم في تلك
الهجمات نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الرسائل التي اراد تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه توجيهها باعلانه
المسؤوليه عن تفجيرات
بروكسل وماه التداعي السياسيه والامنيه
والاجتماعيه المحتمله لهذه التفجيرات في
بلجيكا
[موسيقى]
واوروبا بتفجيرات اسقطت نحو 90 شخصا بين
قتيل وجريح استقبلت بروكسل يوم الثلاثاء
رغم انها كانت تعيش قبل ذلك باربعه ايام
اجواء تاهب امني تحسبا لرد فعل انتقامي
الاعتقال الامن البلجيكي صلاح عبد السلام
المشتبه به الرئيسي في هجمات باريس في
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي لم يترك تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه مجالا للتكهنات بشان
هويه الجهه المنفذه فسارع الى تبني
التفجيرات التي قال ان مجموعه من مقاتليه
نفذتها بعبوات
واحزمه ناسفه نتابع تقرير زياد بركات ثم
نفتح النقاش مع ضيوفنا
من ضرب هنا اوجع فبركسل ليست مجرد مدينه
بل رمزيا ومؤسساتي هي عاصمه اوروبا صباحها
كان مختلفا هذه المره ففي ذروته شهد
مطارها هجومين متزامنين وثمه ثالث استهدف
محطه مترو غير بعيد عن مؤسسات تابعه
للاتحاد الاوروبي في المدينه تلك كما توضح
سريعا هجمات متزامنه لا يق قوم بها افراد
بل تنظيمات عابره للدول او اجهزه
استخباراتيه وهنا في اوروبا ثم وقود يصب
على النار وثمه مستفيدون ربما عبر العالم
مما يحدث من نفذ تفجيرات بروكسل ولماذا لم
يكن هذا سؤالا يستحق التفكير ماليا او على
الاقل انتظار نتائج التحقيقات لدى بعض
الساسه اليمينيين من واشنطن الى دمشق
والضحيه الجنوبيه انه الاسلام المتطرف يشن
حربه علينا
يقول مرشح جمهوري محتمل للرئاسه الامريكيه
فيما لم يستطع حزب الله اللبناني اخفاء
شماته علنا فمن نفذ هم التكفيريون الذين
تحاربهم سوريا واوروبا تكتوي بنار اشعل ضد
سوريا اما دمشق فوجدتها فرصه لتع بروكسل
وتقرع اوروبا ولو بمنطق تعسفي لماذا
تدعمون مجموعات ارهابيه وتصفونها
بالمعتدين ولندن يتقدم الهاجس الامني على
ما سواه وثمت ما هو اخطر انه ايحاء يتجول
الان في الاجواء بان الارهابيين ينامون في
اسرتنا وفي احيائه ثمت مهاجرون الطر لقطع
البحار بحثا عن الامان سيصبحون محل شك
وثمت دين سماوي يشيطن هو ومتنه والحدود لن
تعود مفتوحه كالسابق على ان تلك تظل جزءا
من العده النظريه لتيارات شعبو ولا تكفي
تفسير ظاهره بالغه التعقيد وصفها الاوضح
هو الارهاب اما اسبابها فاقد من ان تختزل
او تنسب الى دين سماوي من نفذ تفجيرات
بروكسل ومن قبلها باريس كان يعيش فيهما
ربما ولد في بلده فرنسيه صغيره او في شمال
بلجيكا درس في مدارسها ومشى في شوارعها
وتناول وجباته في مطاعمها فهل هي ازمه
اندماج ام ادماج مسؤوليه الافراد ام الدول
هنا يتحدث البعض عن تهميش يتوحش ونظره
نمطيه تدرج المسلم في خانه تحول دون ان
يصبح مواطنا واذا اضيف هذا الى شعور
بالاقصاء والنبذ تتولد ربما رغبات ثاريه
تجد من يعززها بنموذج القاتل المنتقم
والبح والحق بالنار ينفتح المشهد على ما
هو اعقد من التحليلات النمطيه القائمه على
الاختزال ومن ثم الشيطنه والمعالجات
الامنيه وحسب يصبح الامر سياسيا بحسب
هؤلاء يجد حلوله في السياسه نفسها برامج
ادماج حقيقيه في الداخل اعتراف اكبر
بالمكون المسلم والاقليات وخارجيا تفكيك
نموذج القاتل باسم عقيده او دين عظيم
بتفكيك اسبابه وهي هنا انظمه دكتاتوريه لم
تجد وانصارها حرجا من الشماته ببروكسل
عندما ضربت
فاوجع وضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوف
فينا في الاستديو الاستاذ حسام شاكر
الخبير في الشؤون الاوروبيه وينضم الينا
من باريس فرانسوا جيري رئيس المعهد
الفرنسي للتحليل الاستراتيجي وينضم الينا
من عمان الاستاذ حسن ابو هنيه الخبير في
الجماعات الاسلاميه نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا
وابدا من باريس معك فرانسوا جيري لو بحثنا
في مضامين الرساله التي حملتها هذه
التفجيرات حتما سنسال ماذا يريد تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه من
بروكسل يجب ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار ما
يريده تنظيم الدوله وما هو قادر
عليه لقد تبنى تنظيم الدوله هذه الهجمات
من دون ان نتمكن من القول انه تم التخطيط
لها وتنظيمها عن قصد اذا هل ان في ذلك
انتقام بعد اعتقال عدد من الاشخاص
الذين يعتبرون مسؤوليه بشكل اساسي عن
هجمات باريس الث ع من نوفمبر
2015 هل في ذلك هجوم جديد متعمد ام هل
اننا هنا نتعاطى مع استفاقه من قبل اشخاص
لم يعد لديهم اي شيء يخسروه وبالتالي
يحاولون ان يتسببوا باكبر قدر من
الضرر وانا لا اعتقد شخصيا ان طبعا تبني
داعش للعمليه مهم ولكن لا ارى في ذلك
اشاره قوه او
اشاره تعاظم لدور داعش لان هذا التنظيم
يحاول ان يتسبب بالاذى بكل طريقه ممكنه
وهو طبعا كان متجذرا في هذا المعقل عن
بذلك بلجيكا وهو الان يواجه الصعوبه
ويحاول بكل السبل ان يتسبب بهذا الاذى من
دون ان يكون له غرض حقيقي او استراتيجيه
حقيقيه ولكن مره اخرى بث الرعب يفيده
دائما وهذا ما رايناه اليوم في بروكسل
السيد حسن ابو هانيه هل ترى فعلا مثل
فرانسوا جيري ان هذا الفعل هو سلوك من ليس
لديه ما يخسر في النهايه ام ان هناك رساله
محدده ذهبت الى عنوانها ما فحوى الرساله
التي ارسلتها او ارسلها تنظيم الدوله الى
بروكسل لا اعتقد ان رساله التنظيم واضحه
وربما وكاله اعماق التي تبنت التابعه
لتنظيم الدوله بالتاكيد التي تبنت الهجوم
افصحت بشكل واضح وصريح بان بلجيكا هي
منخرط في سياق التحالف الدولي الذي انشئ
منذ ايلول سبتمبر 2014 و شارك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذا التحالف وكذلك
فرنسا وبالتالي هذه الهجمات انتقاميه هذا
امر واضح يعني شاهدنا هذا النمط من
الهجمات الارتداديه بعد الاحتلال الامريكي
للعراق 2003 وشهد وبالتالي شاهدنا هجمات
مدريد انذاك 2004 ثم هجمات لندن 2005 اذا
على الرغم من ان من الطبيعه الترهيب
والمتوحشه لاستراتيجيات وتكتيكات هذا
التنظيم لكن الرساله السياسيه هي الابرز
وه وه واضحه بان هناك عمليه تحالف دولي
تشكل وعمليات قصف لمواقع تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه في العراق وسوريا وهذا جزء من
هذا الحساب وبالتالي يمكن فهم رساله تنظيم
الدوله الامر الى مشاركه بلجيكا يعني
مشاركتها تقريبا تكد تكون رمزيه في هذا
التحالف لا نرى لها يعني حضور عسكري قوي
في عمل قوات التحالف
الدولي هل هذا مبرر كافي برا هذا صحيح
ولكن هذا يرتبط لا اعتقد ان يعني هذا هذا
جزء من من الواقع لكن الجزء الاهم هي
امكانات وقدرات التنظيم التشغيليه تبدو ان
هناك تمكن التنظيم كما اشرتم في الث عشر
من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر من تنفيذ هجمات
باريس وبالتالي التنظيم حيثما تمكن من
القدره بمعنى اذا توافرت القدره التشغيليه
والتمويليه وعمليات التجنيد والاستقطاب
فالتنظيم سوف يضرب هو اعلن بشكل واضح
وصريح ويعلن بشكل مباشر بان جميع هذه
البلدان الاوروبيه المنخرط في اطار
التحالف هي هدف لهجمات هذا التنظيم
وبالتالي يعني يترتب الامر ليس فقط على ال
الانخراط ومدى سعه او اكثر ولكن بالتاكيد
على الامكانات والقدرات لان نشاهد ان
بلجيكا هي تبدو ان ح خاص نوعا ما خاصره
رخوه معظم منفذي هجمات باريس كانوا في من
بعضهم من اصول بلجيكيه عبد الحميد ابو عود
وصلاح عبد السلام وابراهيم عبد السلام
وغيرهم وكذلك ايضا يعني هذه الهجمات الان
في هذه المنطقه من الواضح ان هناك اشكالات
عديده قد تبدو استخباريه وامنيه في على
صعيد الامن في بلجيكا وبالتالي استثمر
التنظيم هذه النقطه من الضعف وبالتالي
التنظيم حيث ما وجد هناك نوع من الثغرات
الامنيه سوف يعمل على استثمارها
واستغلالها ثم سال عن
ال استاذ حسن من هنا احلنا الى السؤال عن
الثغرات الامنيه والسؤال الى لك الاستاذ
حسام شاكر على اعتبار انك خبير بالشؤون
الاوروبيه يعني اربعه ايام بعد اعتقال
صلاح عبد السلام ووسط كل هذه التعزيزات
الامنيه المشدده التي تشهدها بروكسل بعد
اعتقال صلاح عبد السلام تاتي هذه
التفجيرات لتضرب في نقاط حساسه وحيويه
يعني في المطار في محطه مترو يعني ما نجعت
اذا هذه الاجراءات الامنيه اذا كانت ستضرب
مقرات حيويه بهذه بهذه السهوله هذه هي
المعضله اليوم مع الاعتداءات التي تتم
تحصد الارواح نلحظ اليوم ما جرى في يوم
الثلاثاء الدامي كما يقال في بروكسل هناك
اعتداءات داميه موجعه اوقعت اعدادا هائله
من الضحايا الابرياء هذه الاعداد تمت او
هذه الاستهدافات تمت في اماكن سهله
الاستهداف يعني عندما تتحدث عن محطه قطار
يتدفق اليها يوميا الوف مؤلفه من الناس
المطار في الصاله التي لا توجد فيها تفتيش
عمليا تمت هذه الضربه المؤلمه والموجع انا
اتصور هذا يعطي انطباعا بان هناك اراده في
ايقاع ضحايا الاهداف سهله رخوه الى حد ما
التزامن ربما هو الصعب هذا معادله صحيحه
لكن نعلم جيدا اذا كان هناك في الفعل بنيه
حقيقيه كما نتصور كان هناك اهداف
استراتيجيه في بروكسل هناك النيتو على
سبيل المثال حلف شمال الاطلسي لم يستهدف
لانه يحتاج ربما هناك صينات معينه اتصور
اليوم المعضله ان عمليات القتل الجماعي
تتم في اماكن سهله هناك جهه تتبنى كل ما
يمكن تنفيذه على الارض هناك ما يسمى
بالفرنشايز هناك من يتبنى فكره ينفذ وهناك
من يقوم باعلان المسؤوليه عن ذلك اتصور
نحتاج الى تحليل هذه الظاهره في المقابل
هناك تحديات حقيقيه الخطير اليوم الذي
نشهده انه الحديث عن المسلمين مثلا في هذه
اللحظه هناك ثلاثه اشخاص اعتبر انهم
منفذون الاعتداءات اليوم تم الزج ب
300,000 مسلم في بروكسل في هذه اللحظه هذه
عمليه صعبه و نذكر انه قبل سنه تحديدا
اسقطت طائره المانيه على متنها 250 شخص
على الاقل وتم يعني ماتوا جميعا ولم يسال
عن السياقات الثقافيه والاجتماعيه لمنس
على اي مستوى الزج بالمسلمين في هذا الش
انا اتصور ان البحث عن تفسيرات ثقافيه
ودينيه واجتماعيه للقتل للارهاب الى اخره
بشكل قائي هي ممارسه تمييز واتصور هذا
ينبغي ان يتم التنبه اليه بشكل جيد نحن
نعلم ان هناك في المجتمعات الاوروبيه في
بروكسل مثلا هناك بالفعل ظواهر اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه هناك مهمشون ربما ولكن لا يمكن
ان ازوج بمكونات مجتمعيه فيها ناجحين فيها
حالات اندماج ايجابيه جميعا في خانه
المشتبه بهم انا اصم احياء بكاملها بانها
اعشاش تطرف وارهاب هذا لا يخدم في نهايه
المطاف برنامج لدي ماج والتعايش وهنا
نتحدث عن اوروبا بشكل عام ام عن ب بشكل
واضح وفي اوروبا بشكل عام على تفاوت في
النماذج واتصور هذه اللحظه تحتاج الى قدر
عالي جدا من الحساسيه والوعي والتمييز هل
يستثمر اذا في هذا التهميش طالما ان
الدراسات تثبت بان اكثر هؤلاء الذين يتم
تجنيدهم في تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه هم ناس
تم يعني تجنيدهم داخل السجون مثلا داخل
السجون هناك بعض عندهم خلفيات اجراميه
بعضهم عندهم هزات نفسيه كما اظهرت دراسات
معينه وايضا هي اضطراب في فهم العالم
العالم هناك مظالم كثيره وبالتالي تتداخل
السياسات الخارجيه وعدم فهمها عند بعض ال
نعم هناك ايضا تقاطع يبدو بين الجماعات
الجهاديه وجماعات تهريب وبيع المخدرات في
هناك مسالك مشتركه بكل تاكيد هناك خلفيات
اجراميه لبعض من نفذ هذا هناك ازمات نفسيه
ولكن المحصله اننا ايضا امام جيل جديد من
العمليات الارهابيه قبل 30 سنه كان هناك
الارهاب الاحمر كمثال في اوروبا لم يكن
لديه قدره التشبيك الالكتروني حيازه هذه
الممرات المفتوحه الى اخره اليوم تابعنا
هذا المساء في بعض المواقع الالكترونيه
الاوروبيه الزج باللاجئين ان هذا هو الثمن
من استقبل اللاجئين في اوروبا هذا خطاب
خطير لانه يؤدي لمزيد من التهميش ويؤدي
الى نتائج وقيمه العواقب فيما بعد اليوم
اذا تم اشعار مكون معين في المجتمعات
الاوروبيه انه حاضن للارهاب هذه رساله
خاطئه تؤدي لنتائج وخيمه لا تخدم عمليه
مكافحه الارهاب في النهايه نعم اذا هذا
الجزء المتعلق بالتداعيات المحتمله على
الجاليات المسلمه والعربيه في اوروبا سوف
نناقشه بعد فاصل قصير نناقش
التداعيات المحتمله لهذه التفجيرات
تفجيرات الثلاثاء في بروكسل ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش تفجيرات بروكسل
وتداعياتها السياسيه والامنيه والاجتماعيه
المحتمله في اوروبا نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد
واعود اليك في باريس سيد فرانسوا جيري
واضح ان هناك حديث قوي الان عن طبيعه
التداعيات التي
ستجر هذه التفجيرات على المستوى السياسي
على المستوى الامني على المستوى الاجتما
بالنسبه للجاليات ايضا العربيه والمسلمه
هناك ماذا تتوقع ان يحدث
كتدابير منحطه والحذر عندما نحاول ان نحدد
تداعيات هذه الهجمات من دون ادنى شك تاتي
هذه الهجات وهذا هو وهدفها بكل الاحوال
لتعزز شعور الرعب والخوف
وتبث الشقاق في قلب المجتمعات الديمقراطيه
وهي مجتمعاتنا
والهدف طبعا هو
فصل ال الاطياف المختلفه من المجتمع وان
يتم رفض على سبيل المثال المواطنين
الفرنسيين البلجيكيين اولئك المقيمين في
فرنسا وان يتم الاشاره بالاصبع الى المسلم
باعتباره خطرا محتملا هذه طريقه ايضا
لاستخدام الظاهره الحاليه ظاهره المهاجرين
واللاجئين من خلال
اعتبارهم خطرا
ايضا اذا ما وقعنا في هذا الفخ لانه
فخ
اعتقد اننا بهذه الطريقه غير طريقه عمل
مجتمعاتنا وقد نخسر بهذه الطريقه الطبيعه
الديمقراطيه لدولنا
ولحمات اعتقد كذلك انه لابد من ان نكون
حذرين جدا بمعنى اخر ان ناخذ كل التدابير
الامنيه الضروريه وان نعزز من فعليه هذه
التدابير من دون ان نتسبب
بفجوه او ب فصل داخل مجتمعاتنا وكاننا
لانه لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن المسلمين من جهه
وعن الفرنسيين وال بلجيكيين وغيره من جهه
اخرى نحن بلد واحد نحن شعب واحد نحن مجتمع
اوروبي واحد بغض النظر
عن
الاعتبارات الدينيه او الثقافيه وما
اليه
الان لابد كذلك من ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
التداعيات على المدى
الطويل يفترض ذلك طبعا استراتيجيه اكثر
فاعليه فيما يتعلق بداعش يجب ان ننظر الى
ما يحصل اليوم وكيف تتفاعل هذه المجتمعات
مجتمعاتنا تضرب اليوم
وتشعر بضروره حمايه نفسها واليوم تنقصنا
استراتيجيه ترمي الى ضرب داعش
وليس لدينا ما يكفي من التحرك طبعا لدينا
عمليات القصف في سوريا وفي العراق ولكن
هذه العمليات لا تكفي اعتقد
اننا سالبون بمعنى اننا لا نتحرك بما يكفي
على مستوى الافكار وعلى مستوى الافعال ال
والتحركات العسكريه ليس لدينا مبادرات
كافيه وما يجري اليوم يثبت ان
استراتيجيتنا غير كافيه وليست
الاستراتيجيه الصحيحه لابد من ان نغير من
هذه الاستراتيجيه ولابد من ان تكون
افعالنا اكثر
هجوميه افعالنا يجب ان تكون جديده وذلك
لكي نتصدى بها للخطر المتي من داعش من دون
ان نتلقى الضربات ونحن
ننتظر نتلقى هذه الضربات مرارا وتكرارا
ومجددا ونحن ما زلنا ننتظر يجب علينا ان
نصبح اكثر نشاطا في افعالنا ويجب ان نمسك
نحن بزمام المبادره التي خسرناها ولا يجب
ان نسمح لمجموعه مثل داعش بان تمسك هي
بالمبادره في الميدان ا كان ذلك في الشرق
الاوسط او حتى على اراضينا نحن اذا ثمه
تغيير في الاستراتيجيه بات ضروريا يجب ان
يرتكز من جهه على توثيق العرى داخل
مجتمعاتنا وفي صفو في مواطنينا ومن جهه
اخرى على الالتزام بالحاق ضربات بهذا
العدو الذي برايي لا يمكن ان نفعل اي شيء
الا استخدام القوه هؤلاء اشخاص تركز على
استخدام القوه سيد فرانسوا اعذرني على
المقاطعه فقط لانه بقيت معنا دقائق قليله
من امر
البرنامج السيد حسن ابو هنيه واضح ان
السيد فرانسوا جيري يركز على المقاربه
امنيه ووجوب تشديد القبضه الامنيه على هذه
الجماعات انت من خبرتك بطريقه وطبيعه عمل
هذه الجماعات المتطرفه هل تنفع معها
المقاربه الامنيه
بتشديد القبضه الامنيه كما كان يقول السيد
فرانسوا قبل
قليل لا اعتقد هذا بات امر منتهي النقاش
يعني لم يعد هناك جدوى من النقاش المقاربه
الامنيه المقاربه الامنيه العسكريه
بالتاكيد هي ضروريه ولكن وحدها لم تفلح
على الاطلاق منذ احداث الحادي ع من سبتمبر
ب شاهدنا هناك تطور لانماط الارهاب
والجماعات المتطرفه بشكل كبير وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث دائما عن مقاربه تكامليه شموليه
تشك يعني تقع المقاربه العسكريه الامنيه
في احد اركانها لكن الاركان الاخرى هي
ضروريه على الصعيد الايديولوجي الثقافي
وعلى الصعيد الاهم وهو السياسي الاقتصادي
لانه في النهايه هذه الجماعات تتشكل هذه
الايديولوجيا من خلال قضايا عديده في
المنطقه قضايا الدكتاتوريه قضايا الاحتلال
قضايا الفقر التهميش كل هذه مسائل هي في
النهايه تخلق بيئه خصبه للتجنيد والتعبئه
والاستقطاب وبالتالي انت قد تستخدم القوه
العسكريه في قهر تنظيم لفتره ما ثم يعاود
بشكل اكثر قوه كما هو ظاهره تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه الان في العراق وسوريا التي
باتت تسيطر على مساحات واسعه وتتمدد في
مناطق عديده سواء في العالم العربي
والاسلامي وتستطيع ان تضرب حتى في اوروبا
وشمال امريكا اذا الامور تحتاج الى مقاربه
اكثر تكاملا وشمولا تبحث عن الاسباب
والشروط والظروف الموضوعيه العميقه التي
ادت الى ظهور هذه الظ طيب استاذ حسام شاكر
المقاربه المطلوبه الان لهذه الظاهره على
المستوى السياسي والامني والاجتماعي في
اوروبا ان نلحظ ان هناك مدارس خرجت هؤلاء
الشباب لابد ان يبحث في النظام التعليمي
هناك فرص عمل لابد ان تبحث ما واقع سوق
العمل ايضا هناك سجون اخرجت هؤلاء هناك
ظروف اقتصاديه واجتماعيه هناك خطاب يتم
استخدامه خطاب ديني للتجنيد خطاب زائف
لابد من تفكيكه والتعامل معه هناك ايضا
حاجه حقيقيه وجاده لمراجعه السياسات
الخارجيه اوروبا تخسر اخلاقيا عندما تصافح
مستبدين دين قتلوا شعوبهم عندما تدعم نظام
احتلال هذه لابد ان تكون واضحه من يريد ان
يخرج بمعادله حقيقيه لمعالجه هذه الظاهره
كما قال الاستاذ حسن تحتاج الى مقاربه
شامله وجريئه ايضا تراجع السياسات بعمق
ولا توفر مبررات في نفس الوقت للارهاب
الاعمى هذه حاله لابد منها لابد ان تكسب
الجاليات المسلمه بكل تاكيد هل هذا ما
سيحدث برايك انا في تقديري انا متخوف من
صعود اليمين المتطرف واستخدامه وهو يتغذى
من هذه الفوضه بالتاكيد تصريحات ترامب هذا
المساء لا لا تعطي اي انطباع مبشر في هذا
هناك من يستفيد من هذا يوظفه كثير من
وسائل الاعلام في اوروبا تستخدم هذه
الملفات بطريقه مسيئه وغير مسؤوله نحتاج
الى مقاربه حقيقيه وهذه لحظه للعقل
والتعقل في اوروبا وهناك اصوات تطالب
بوضوح بضروره اجراء مراجعه حقيقيه الحل
الامني جرب منذ باريس وقبل باريس مطلوب
اجراء مقاربات امنيه لكن واحدها لن تنجز
معال وتحصين للمجتمعات الاوروبيه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الاستاذ حسام شاكر الخبير في
الشؤون الاوروبيه شكرا لك ونشكر من باريس
الاستاذ فرانسوا جيري رئيس المعهد الفرنسي
للتحليل الاستراتيجي ونشكر ضيفنا من عمان
الاستاذ حسن ابو هنيه الخبير في الجماعات
الاسلاميه بهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد لكم
منا اطيب المنى والى اللقا
[موسيقى]
kom